- So Chrissy Teigen just happened to be
at BuzzFeed as I was writing this post,
and I told her, "Your egg's didn't win,"
and she said, "God damn it,"
and she just walked away.
(music)
Today I'm gonna be making five famous
scrambled egg recipes to find out
which one is actually the best.
I set up five recipes to replicate
exactly how the celebrities do it.
We have Gordon Ramsay,
Martha Stewart,
Heston Blumenthal,
Anthony Bourdain,
and then for a wild card,
I have Chrissy Teigen.
I lined up all the
ingredients on the recipes.
I measured them precisely,
and I got toast ready for all of them,
so we can all try it.
So the whole playing
field's completely level.
Three of my friends
are gonna come down and
taste them with me to see
which one is actually the best.
So let's get this scrambled
egg showdown crackin'.
(chicken squawks)
Anthony Bourdain's eggs.
He whips them just until
there's a ripple of white
and yellow, not all the way.
And then he cooks them
in a hot pan with butter.
And he cooks them in a figure eight motion
until they're cooked, and
this one cooks really fast.
(music)
Martha Stewart follows
a pretty traditional way
to scramble her eggs.
She thinks that if you have good eggs,
you don't need to add anything to them.
So she cooks them in a pan
with butter on low heat.
Very traditional, and she pushes them all
towards the center in this ripple motion
to create kind of these ribbons,
that are like really beautiful.
And then she seasons with salt and pepper
right at the end, and that's it.
(upbeat music)
Gordon Ramsay's internet famous eggs,
cooks them in a pot, he serves
them with chunks of butter
and he puts them on a low
burner for 30 seconds,
he takes them off,
stirs them for 20 more seconds,
then puts them on for 30 seconds,
puts them on again for
the last 20 seconds,
and throws some creme fresh in
to cool them down really
quickly, and that's it.
(music)
Chrissy Teigan's scrambled eggs are
I'm guessing, obviously gonna be good
because she puts a whole
quarter cup of cream in them.
And she cooks them with
three tablespoons of butter,
so it's just fat on fat.
She cooks them on super low heat
and this takes about 20 minutes,
it's so low heat, actually.
She seasons the egg mixture itself
so I think these ones,
they're gonna taste like butter and cream
so they're gonna be pretty freakin' good.
(music)
Heston Blumenthal has
a very strange method,
when he combines milk,
cream, eggs, salt and pepper
in a double boiler with a whisk.
And he puts them over
gently simmering water
and stirs them with a rubber spatula
until they're just barely cooked.
The gentle heat is supposed to keep them
pretty soft and moist.
And I'm so sorry for using the word moist.
(music)
- It's whatever, it's
literally whatever eggs.
- It's very flat.
- Yeah.
- It looks like it was
on the bottom of the pan
and they like just scraped it off.
- They didn't mix it well,
look at all the colors.
- White, yellow, yellow
- Yeah, it's like it's not very mixed.
- They're standard, they're okay.
- Who is it, Anthony Bourdain.
- I can see how he got this texture,
he has that figure eight technique,
so it's not mixed very well.
- Don't do the figure eight.
- No, no figure eight.
- These are a little richer.
- The last one was like,
anybody making those eggs
this one was like probably like
your friend, and he's like,
"Ooh yeah, let me just put some
milk in it and whip it up."
And you're like, "Oh cool, thanks."
- Martha.
- This is like how I make my eggs.
- Elevated basic eggs, which
is like what Martha does best.
- Did you just call Martha Stewart basic?
(giggles)
- Ooh, these look different.
- These are thick.
- Oh, it's all butter.
- It taste like there's
cheese in it, kinda,
but I know there's not.
- This is what I would eat when
I'm like, been good all week
and I'm just gonna splurge on breakfast.
- Gordon Ramsey
- Ooh.
- I can see it though,
Gordon is like the master.
- I think this is diner quality.
- These are my favorite eggs.
- No muss, no fuss kinda thing
maybe a little bit of milk, but that's it.
- Who is it, who is it?
- Oh Chrissy!
- Oh my god!
- Oh no, Chrissy Teigan.
- The queen, okay, I can see that.
I'm gonna have more.
- Is that just butter?
- This looks like a
gigantic slice of cheese.
- Holy crap, this not eggs.
- Oh my god.
- This is just cheese.
- This is butter and cheese-
- Oh my god, this is so rich.
- With like one egg in it.
- With a little bit of egg.
- This is like splash of egg.
- This doesn't taste like egg.
- This is the richest egg
dish I've ever tasted.
- These are good, I want this recipe.
- Heston Blumenthal
- That's the fine dining chef in the UK.
- I can eat all this.
(music)
- So on the count of three,
let's say who our favorite was.
- Okay.
- Ready?
Three, Two, One
- [Together] Heston Blumenthal
- Did you say Chrissy Teigan?
- Yes! Hers was the best.
- Are you kidding me?
- Oh my god.
- It had like texture, it was creamy.
- We love you Heston.
Chrissy we still love you
but your eggs suck, sorry.
- Haters.
- They're not good.
(music)